[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful voice
featuring not only boys but
girls
i was gonna say colleen's here sounds
[Applause]
this is the sound of the ladies here
like a tiger
that's what they sound like
don't change for the rest of the day i
appreciate it dude i feel like i feel
like i i feel pretty cool i feel like
i'm channeling joe right now someone
with cauliflower ears wear this hat is
pretty weird
it's like you got too many hobbies bro
yeah yeah yeah just do one thing yeah do
you fight or do you adventure because
you can't do both i just want an
adventure now yeah bro i barely fight
don't act like you would say that [ __ ]
to someone with cauliflower
hey you look like you belong in el
salvador thanks man i feel like i look
like a scarecrow or something that's
like a nicholas dundee
nicholas dundee i like that i feel like
only joe could pull that off now we're
gonna try to you wanted to give me props
i did give you processing you [ __ ]
held that no cuz it sounded good and
then i was like i know what he [ __ ]
did he did a [ __ ] pun again the
glasses on too though the glasses will
make it there you go i think i'm gonna
break my glasses on this guys you look
like an orthodox jewish person she's
almost poke as i am don't poke my eyes
bro
what do i look like cooler than you did
before literally like 30 seconds hella
blind
you look like you're hiding cocaine in
your hat and trying to get on the plane
you're like acting blind like what
[Laughter]
how did you
fail
caricature of a chinese man oh yeah like
if you had sleeves that do this oh dude
that's that gently's cool accountant
you know what i'm talking about
the hands going dude
they're just very stoic you want me to
build your whale world
you're the one leasing all the other
chinese people i'm the foreman huh yeah
yeah yeah yeah hurry up over there
no one's ever that needy
working at the pacific railroad dude
oh this is self-racism i love it i know
man
i love it it's blindism bro who's this
this mine i got it in mexico for 30
bucks wow and i got this at chichen itza
that chipped bro i know you really try
to sell one of those tours but i wanted
to support the locals that doesn't sound
as crazy as i thought it would
absolutely
it's a cougar that's why the the ladies
joke yeah yeah our pants our crotches
are so wet right now look at that
dry it up dry it up you're married get
out of here
[Laughter]
try it out just go where is this more
like a fan
you're trying to [ __ ] air dry it and
also tell them
speaking of go away would you do this
yesterday joe
how did you do this nice segment dude
i'm really strong but that wasn't me i
saw joe literally shut up you primed it
for me okay so we went golfing yesterday
we thought it was going to be really
really cute to spend some time outside
of the office i thought it was cute i
liked it i was adorable no it was so
funny you nicked it and just don't talk
yeah you son of a [ __ ] you were saying
that you're gonna come but then you
didn't come um you know what ended up
happening that's not true
this [ __ ] got me into golf and i
said let's go on a date it was supposed
to be between me and you and you wanted
to invite all these [ __ ] and they
ruined it that's how you get out of a
date so this is why you broke his club
because you were jealous that he invited
all of us yeah and that's why i didn't
go that's why i didn't go and he was a
thing he didn't even [ __ ] teach me
golfers he was supposed to teach me gold
i will admit i did i wasn't sure that
joe was actually going to be into it
because i had brought it up and you
talked about it and it was just another
one of those things that joe talks about
and joe talks about a lot of things a
lot of things yeah uh and i get it to
[ __ ] bro and then yes you do uh batch it
and then he texts me on i think
wednesday said bro we're gonna go
golfing i was like dude i'm super down
text me on thursdays like yo we going
golfing i was like oh [ __ ] that's how
you know he's down dude oh he confirmed
with you twice triple confirmed so then
that's why i was like all right cool
let's go we all show up to monterey
hills country uh club whatever the golf
thing is one mile from here something
like that i don't know luminaria it's
pretty far away it's really far away
we're in uh canada i don't know if they
um
earned their country club status why not
i think it's just they're not ballers
they're just golf golf yeah it's a it's
it's a public judgmental of you dude
yeah anyways
so uh i brought out one set of clubs the
thing is i never really bought clubs i
just got into golfing i suck at it so
jason park bro you have a white glove
you can't suck at something you don't
have a [ __ ] we saw that swing dude i
don't have a glove this swing was clean
dude it's not about me right now um so i
brought
some clubs that i borrowed from jason
park and he let me borrow this
taylormade driver do you call him jason
parker do you just call him jason like
is it like every time what's up jason
park it's like anthony lee i don't
understand why you're upset with this no
no no i'm curious because i don't go
like hey
first of all you don't even say joseph
right that's why i'm like who's jason
parker he's one of the kinjas we don't
even always say the park when you're
talking about an actual park he's a
[ __ ] kinja he's a [ __ ] kid wait is
there multiple jason's is that why he's
never gonna finish the story
yeah we have multiple jason we have a
jason lynn we don't want that we have a
jason park no because yesterday remember
uh we're going down the list of hinges
right which ones you would kill yeah i
didn't hear jason park once cause they
only got to like nine and there was 40
of them
you got too many fake friends dude what
does he do what does he do in the kenjus
kendricks
why is he so rich with that [ __ ] he's
korean koreans oh that's true that's
true they have like a whole set come out
the [ __ ] when they're born when
they're born they they have a whole golf
ball every korean father wants their son
to be like tiger woods that's true and
then if it doesn't work that's when they
kind of give a pope yeah and then
they're like maybe go doctor yeah that
may be good you know what i'm saying
dancers anyways that's not even we get
there and then right away bart's already
like you all want to hit bombs well you
presented it wait wait wait wait
yeah next to you i'm dry like all the
time um
blow the cougar thank you
she was splashing around this morning
all right
well i mean we were training
um so he had two bags one of them it was
like his clubs the other bags he's like
this is the women's bag is nina nina's
yes you didn't say that you said the
women's clubs that's what you said
because and then everyone immediately
was like we don't want those
you didn't even want those i don't want
those
just in case somebody identified with
women's clubs you know you should have
longer clubs because you're tall right
exactly which i went to the man once
anyways so bart right away i said
everybody should probably warm up with
the shoulder clips and he pulls out the
driver right away i even said sure you
can hit this is i just want to whack it
as far as possible
and it takes doesn't sound like me
i've never heard him say that once
doesn't sound like me
he's a very we need to show the footage
of him [ __ ] hitting this [ __ ] and
winding up like a goddamn weed whackers
uh we there's a ig story
it wasn't bart we're gonna put all that
[ __ ] in here it's hilarious here i gotta
show at least this one so like show the
first one this is the first one that's
literally the first one okay show the
first one dude go so here's ready for it
i got to turn up the volume
i thought you had the video
that is not the first one one the first
one the first one
i'm not that good on my first one this
is the first one that was on the jk yeah
that was the spin down you gotta look at
the end great spin he entered the 360.
oh yeah that's the one that's
that's a home run kept his eyes on it
the whole time because follow through
it's all about follow through yeah
that's the one check your peripherals
okay not to back bart up because we all
know i don't like him right right can we
agree let's see where this goes okay so
did we notice in that video he not once
this never once touched the floor i'm
just that was the first stroke on camera
then there was like six or seven
sequential things where you hit the turf
first multiple times did you hear did
you hear base scout's honor with the
driver i didn't touch the floor once
scout's honor
happened
so then it showed that it's joe's fault
that means it's on joe he put scout
sonar on you dude yeah but it's three of
them it's definitely fine
the boy scouts just got caught with
touching other boys so i don't [ __ ]
believe in that [ __ ]
speak on it
so there's no honor in the scouts
that i didn't touched it one time on the
ground
but it never touched no kids there's
several different buddhas then after
bart used it so we're all playing you're
trying to teach us like you were
genuinely trying to teach everybody he
was like going we had three different
stations and he's trying to go to all
the stations and he's trying to like
show everyone like hand positioning like
you have to put it in between like these
two index fingers
and then after you used it that's what i
heard uh then he got it yeah he was done
no riot and then me so then it's ryan's
fault oh your honor i i don't remember
who came right after me i was the first
person to utilize it
um and my hand on the bible didn't touch
the floor one time and i probably
whacked it underneath i got to be
buddhist and bible yeah yeah yeah
what's inside the bible give me give me
your favorite bible words
favorite chapter [ __ ] corinthians 4
16
thou
burning bush shall smile upon thee
see
truth he knows what's up we're both sda
shut the [ __ ] up joe was never the sda
he lies about it all the time so ryan
after he did not hit the floor
the this place this is more juicier than
the abbreviation
[Laughter]
we gotta get to the bottom of it
i think all i did was hit it once and
then so you think you're not even sure
did you hit the ground with that i
definitely didn't hit the ground i
barely hit the ball i just hit air the
amount of torque this man can generate
from yours is spinning though his hips
are pretty good he's got some good so i
kinetically transferred it down to the
club so even you hitting the air was
impact it was
which one of you [ __ ] saw that it was
loose and you're like um your turn joe
well
show what happened
yeah so we don't have uh the swing
because he you were he was getting a he
was getting a tutorial from the neighbor
next to us and then who the heck
was the neighbor i have evidence i have
a [ __ ] witness to back me up and it's
unbiased yeah he's a fan he's a fan of
all of us so it's equal are you sure
about that meme a little bit more he
didn't like him that much he didn't like
that he's a jk fan
he's not a kindred fan well he didn't
take a photo with me either but he was
giving me pointers
that neck is doing some [ __ ] all i
know is this is the next moment over
time the next moment joe's got a broken
club this one exhibit a in his hand you
know what you need to see right before
that is him coaching me
wait
i have questions
wait watch watch okay geo geo geo
[Music]
anthony's face
he even says i didn't do nothing
who he the witness why would he do
anything it's in your hands no he says
that i didn't [ __ ] hit the ground or
nothing i just hit the ball because the
way that it but i saw with the ball on
the ground i [ __ ] swung it right i
hit the ball
get out of there [ __ ] hit the ball
right hey whoa don't break that sword
man and then at the end of it i felt
something heavy become light and then i
saw at the end of the stick
that it was just a stick and i was like
wait
where did where did the ball and the
head go and i looked around and it was
in the grass and i was like you saw this
[ __ ] i just hit the ball with the [ __ ]
so you threatened your witness was that
after you gave him 200
no he threatened him his mouth was like
this you could cooperate let me see what
he was the next person that saw but but
the funny thing is how how frantically
he was like come on man you saw it right
come on back me up
come on man come on come on you saw that
right you saw that i swear to god i was
like as soon as it went i was like no
one's gonna believe me
you can just hear it in his voice
you gotta frame joe you know he's
innocent because you could hear the
desperation when he was talking to that
random guy and he's like come on man
you've been a jk fan for years right you
remember the good old days
i would never do something like this
[Laughter]
neutral
who do you think is guilty i need more
footage can i see the footage up close
real quick yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
ryan has the actual footage the actual
footage what do you mean yeah this is
the that's right
what is this [ __ ]
what do you think it was edited
it just
cuts
you know
but just like just go by his behavior he
was the last one he was the last one if
you analyze his delivery it's honest
have you played mafia with this man it's
so genuine i've never played bobby with
him
no he could honestly not know what
happened the only reason why maybe bart
is still in question what
why you got to do that to bartlett it's
because of because of other happenings
that go on
i kind of believe everybody
see so i think it's jason park's fault
this is bart being normal
just kidding this is bart not wanting to
look while hitting hey i was learning
from rhinomate
so this dangerous kind of child's play
at the driving range
well i looked so i gotta reset we know
how to party now you're ready right
there you go
personally
this guy brings out a bat
who's hitting golf balls with a bat
when i saw this video i was like man i
wish i [ __ ] went this guy's hitting
golf balls at the driving range with a
bat
so there's some suspect the sound the
sound
i'm glad you showed that evidence
because none of those apparati broke
whoa everything i touched stayed intact
see but i do think funny business is
monkey business and that means
he wasn't very careful which amendment
is that point
i like to point out funny business
business is monkey business
he didn't treat you you're really evil i
mean equal arguments here treat your
did they let you keep that or did you
just take it
it's okay that's it that's his buddies
oh it's his buddy's actions he's
responding
i brought it so even i borrowed my
friend's driver you're not supposed to
be biased in backup parts borrowed my
[ __ ]
she's neutral and she's like he's out of
all the ones that were broken
yeah yeah that's right that's really
unfortunate
i didn't do it you know i think i think
the real culprit is jason park i think
he gave you guys no one's talking about
jason parker you're right you're right
you're right you know what he did
everything
you wanna borrow because you wanna
borrow this huh cause it's broke all
right you want to borrow it huh i do
have a new set of golf clubs
i need a new driver dude right you know
what set up
i got it
that's [ __ ] anthony anthony had
broken it gave it to bart the biggest
muscle guy in the group cause he knew he
was gonna break it second biggest but he
couldn't who's the first
oh okay don't flex bro you're gonna you
hot potatoed us for that club it could
have been any of us
the old hot potato with the driver as
long as it breaks and he hits his money
thank you sneaky starcher
he did hand it to me
because i was like hey which golf club
could i use and you went like this this
one i saw it
and then you could hear the string
symphony just goes like i was like no
don't use this amazing one that hits
bombs
that's what i said barbara was like i
want to hit bombs and he took it and it
came to me like this it's a setup all i
know is these guys were googling
immediately right away the model number
to see how much it comes yeah we felt
bad of course jason though i called i
called jason
oh he did thank you to come on in have a
dead battery oh yeah thank you so much
for me
no you left her atlanta lights on oh
[ __ ] oh
you win give it a give it a couple
minutes again
that is behavior of a club breaker right
now
wait we all flipped it on anthony dude
joe left his lights on guys like that
that
monkey business is going on outside the
golf club and he probably didn't even
know he left his lights on
maybe it was a you know job that is a
clear
that is a clear miss not a clear hit
we're trying to find the person that's
trying to hit the golf clubs me so
everyone else that turned their life i
keep missing well he missed the ball and
hit the ground no no no i never hit the
ground there's no evidence of that
not i hit the ball i just hit the ball
and it went like that
i didn't do it that's not me
i have a witness that man he saw it he
was coaching me when i [ __ ] hit the
ball it flew with the ball that's how
good your swing was that's what did it
go further than the ball
okay we're going to take a genuine vote
right now what is it geo no no let's
vote we're going to take a general
obviously i'm not on the chopping block
i'm purely who's on the chopping block
so we know clearly you two wait why not
you why not you yeah why not you the
judge
ordering my core corinthians i thought
nick's the judge because he wasn't there
sorry about it i think colleen
colleen should be the unbiased judge
yeah
this guy wants me to die i want you to
die i think it's jason park i agree with
him
at just point 85 your fault buddy i
think i think it's natural wear and tear
because i bet jason park hits bombs you
know what i mean yeah is he perfect i
bet he's really good
i bet i bet he's put a lot of mileage or
whatever her ball hits on the [ __ ]
and that that's not even that expensive
thank you we saw you know how much was
it it was 170 bucks what happens when
you cheap out on your golf clubs dude
jason
jason we got to talk to you i think
there's two prime suspects one
jason right
he's korean and he's you don't know what
the [ __ ] and you know they got fire in
them the second one i saw the way
anthony stores golf clubs was careless
trapped in that's true
there's no seat belt right now
every time we go eat i'm like what's
that sound anthony what's that sound and
then he goes oh don't worry it's just
golf clubs in the back and i looked
before and the golf club is literally
you weren't even in my car it was on a
saw and it was going like this
on a song
because yesterday he put his golf clubs
in this bag right yeah and i was like oh
you're going to drive me back to the
office he's like yeah and then we went
to the truck i'm in danger
[Laughter]
are you okay was there any emotional
damage you heard it sound like a cougar
hold on how could you you
[Laughter]
it just went in the trunk that way and i
was like oh no sorry we could go and and
three weeks ago
we were driving like what the [ __ ] is
happening
they're being exposed right everybody
pick up something and throw it and then
anthony was trying to tell me a secret
right he was like
that's a secret and i was like dude we
can't [ __ ] hear all the windows are
down we're going to close the windows
close windows
but there's one you need to oil your
windows
what's wrong with that window
with the driver sticking out of the
window
leave in the comments below who you
believe we're gonna drop these
headlights what do you think the culprit
is or just watch the ig story
and your lights
[Music]
you